i'm uh eric i lead demand generation at
runnerstack but i started in customer
success actually uh which you heard in
the jokes section
um
my background i've done a lot of stuff
in marketing and also have consulted in
building tech stacks
and i've done a lot of work with
customer data as part of marketing
so that's me
i'm ryan i have engineering background
started in customer success as well
came on as kind of our first technical
hire on the u.s side and i've worn a
bunch of hats
eventually ended up in the kind of
pre-sales solution side and so we're
primarily now with some of our strategic
customers and strategic
prospects as well
so
that's us
and what we're going to talk about today
so ryan and i have been runner stack for
almost two years now
and
you know of course we both have like
different kpis now like on the marketing
side um ryan's on the solution side but
when we started we both uh had a charter
to basically
own our internal implementation of our
own product which we kind of called dog
food
and interestingly even though we sort of
split off to different teams we actually
still do this today so we still lead
the implementation and usage of our own
product in our company which is pretty
fun
um so we're sort of like the de facto
team of like internal customer me
who's sort of defining requirements
and ryan as a developer who's acting as
the data engineer
[Music]
so we still do this work and
all these pipelines run all of the data
for like key teams across the entire
company so what we're going to talk
about today
is the journey of where we started
um and then show you kind of where we
are today and then where we're going
and this is a this is a
you know a small group so like feel free
to jump in and interrupt and ask
questions we'd love to answer any
questions
so
let's look at where we started we call
this the pre-seed scrappy stack
so
when when ryan and i started the really
like the company was a handful of people
all engineers basically and so
all engineers and then one sales person
so they set up the most basic stack you
could possibly set up
um so you know google tag manager you
know sort of as a you know pulling in
third-party scripts on the website
running integrations etc um they had
mailchimp wired up to salesforce to
create leads which was
really brittle and a huge mess
it's a dark point for me
yeah ryan was like oh no
um nick's panel was also running um
you know for sort of the like uh
more like user level behavioral data
and we were actually running runner
stack instrumentation on the website and
app and dumping all that raw data to s3
but um
you know pre-seed you don't actually
really have any data right i mean you
have a couple of users in the app and
you know a couple hundred visits on the
website and
um
you know so you don't really have
analytics
and um
this was tough ryan you want to talk a
little bit about the pain here
yeah i mean
first of all it was just hard to figure
out what was going on what was happening
where like i said it was a dark moment
when i realized like we're populating
salesforce via mailchimp why uh it was
because you know the sales guy was the
one that set that up and so really we
had to like step back and figure out you
know okay if we get rid of mailchimp if
we change music mailchimp or how do we
get leads into salesforce and really
just trying to figure out what was doing
what there's a lot of as you can see
manual processes where we're scrubbing
leads and
you know updating
bad data once it's in salesforce so that
we can actually see um
you know who's there and every time one
of our engineers signs up for the apple
test something we're creating a lead in
salesforce so it's just all just a giant
nightmare um
and uh yeah so that was kind of what i
was just for us getting to work so
um
this is so we sort of said okay we're
gonna redo our stack um
so like i said updates to marketing
infrastructure like forms or anything
like that was hugely painful
um you know tag manager is its own
subject which is like a huge mess and
nightmare in one of itself we had really
inconsistent data because we had
instrumentation in google analytics
mixed panel etc
um the other thing was from a tooling
perspective mailchimp was way too
primitive for sort of behavioral based
email campaigns um right you're talking
about like tons of custom fields and
their you know fields have
uh limits uh and all that sort of stuff
um
and then also our reporting needs
started to outstrip uh the ability of or
started to outstrip the ability of the
point solutions analytics tools to solve
those problems so
one example here actually
um that's really interesting i think a
lot of companies run into is the mql
definition that the company agreed upon
had both
required data both from salesforce
right which was a manual flag at that
point that someone like checked a box in
salesforce you know because there was
like you know sdr scrubbing what if
they've killed
a marketing qualified lead
yeah so it was like you know leads come
in someone signs up for the app and then
the lead goes into salesforce and we had
someone on the sales team scrubbing the
lead
you know going and looking on linkedin
how many employees all that sort of
stuff looking at the demographic
information
setting a flag in salesforce and said
okay this is a marketing qualified lead
but then it was also behavioral right
like if someone signed up for a webinar
that wasn't like really high intent to
buy as opposed to someone requesting a
demo
and so this is a really common thing
like it's very difficult to use both
behavioral data and then data that's
flagged in some sort of cloud tool um to
have like a single definition right and
so doing that in like a point analytics
tool like google analytics or mixpanel
or whatever is like pretty challenging
you know or you try to get the
behavioral data into salesforce which is
even worse um
so this is kind of the pain we're
feeling so i took
sort of these problems
um
as a set of requirements and went to
ryan and said okay let's clean all of
this up
you know sort of stop the bleeding of
this pain of integrations and this is
what ryan
built
yeah so this was um
this was kind of our first step and so
this was fun for me to actually get to
build a stack as you can imagine coming
into a data company and seeing uh what
we were doing before was upsetting and
so uh getting to do some actual uh work
using our own products was really
valuable as well because i was on
you know working with customers pretty
heavily at the time and so what we've
got here um just for clarity's sake the
the little rudder stack logo there is um
is basically acting as our motorcycle so
that's all the data that we're
collecting from the front end of our
website from the back into our website
um install sdks right so javascript is
on the front end like node and go sdks
in the back end and all of that
behavioral data and user data is is
flowing through our system
yeah and so we've been able to
completely at this point get rid of the
google tag manager solution um i've been
able to and at this point uh you know
i'm not in the rudder stack dashboard at
all eric's giving me a right key that i
need to initialize the sdk with and then
he's setting up these destinations to
kind of give me me that spec from before
so i'm able to
go to the code level instrument those
events um kind of once and for all and
then begin to pipe that data through
rudder stack so the the cool thing there
is that there's a lot of side benefits
like right like we got to symbolize our
stack we got to actually start using our
product and and kind of you know use it
as intended but we also
um had a lot of site speed and seo
optimizations because we're not carrying
all of the just everything under the sun
shoved into google tag manager um that's
that's hurting the performance of our
website and so um the other thing that's
allowed us to do is we kind of own the
tracking plan at this point no one's
playing around in tag manager adding new
triggers adding new integrations um it's
only the events that i've instrumented
on the front end and the back end and
nothing else is going through our data
set and so
one of the things that we're also able
to do as part of this as you can see uh
we kind of have modified our stack at
the same time because instrumenting all
those events one time uh with the rotor
stack sdk it's now pretty trivial to
just add snowflake as a destination so
now we have data warehouse connected um
as eric mentioned you know
mailchimp was a little primitive for our
growing needs and so you know wired up
mailchimp and immediately sub it out for
customer i o and again no additional
engineering work we haven't touched any
more of the the front end
instrumentation the vacuum
instrumentation that's all just kind of
kind of set and forget at that point so
this time we added
we pulled salesforce data in the
structured data
so that we could use snowflake to
basically just a couple simple joins
and produce the mql number right
um which was difficult to do in other
tools so we had the behavioral data in
the air flowing from the websites and
apps and then we were pulling the
structured data in from salesforce that
had that mql flag that the sales person
was you know checking
um and it was really easy with a couple
joins
and snowflake to get an accurate number
um you know for reporting
yeah so the kind of net result here is
we've eliminated you know a ton of
dependencies a ton of network calls from
our website um we know what data we're
collecting at this point because it's
only events we've instrumented and um
i don't have to worry about integrations
anymore or what they do eric's managing
those in the dashboard i'm not you i'm
not using a mixed panel or salesforce or
google analytics sdk those are all being
handled throughout your stack i don't
care what those payloads look like
everything's just kind of a unified
defense structure um
and so
at this point we're in a pretty good
spot right we feel uh
like trying to pat ourselves with that
until eric customer shoots for me
so that was great like website's working
we're getting the raw data feed of
behavioral events coming through
um which is really nice but of course
the business starts to get more complex
like as they do as they grow
so data was really accurate across all
those destinations because we only had
one source of data which was the router
stack sdks feeding that data into all of
these downstream tools right the
integrations work was gone and so we
have you know sort of complete accuracy
across systems
now
when you start to have accuracy across
your systems people start using data
more and the more you use data
the more you want to answer like
different types of questions and do more
interesting things with data
so the things that came up at this point
were so sales wanted third party
enrichment um of the leads right so
they're like well it'd be great to use a
clear bit and then we wouldn't have to
go manually scrub all these leads and
linkedin and all that sort of stuff
right
well the clear bit plug-in for
salesforce at us you know this was sort
of i think post-seed stage right but it
was still really really expensive right
but they're like it would be great to
not have to manually swap the leads
right
they were also which i know this is a
huge surprise sales was changing the
values in the lead source field
okay great uh and we're you know sending
these payloads through rudder stack when
someone fills out a form or request demo
or whatever
you know so that causes problems
as ryan said marketing on the marketing
side we really needed to filter out
emails right internal emails you know
for
you know our engineers who are signing
up for the app to test things even
locally right like all the sdks were
running in there
um and then we also needed data from the
email platform and snowflake because we
wanted to stitch the customer journey
together right so we had all the
behavioral events going through which is
great but now we're starting to send
people email and we wanted to see like
okay is the email actually like moving
the needle and again like you can't do
that in an analytics deal you have to do
that in the warehouse
product decided they wanted to use
amplitude for product analytics even
though we already had a mixpanel
instance but it's like okay well you
know you're a team lead and it's your
budget you can use that
and at this point you know the company
was growing a little bit so we started
having people sign up that were like
exciting logos and so everyone wanted
the notifications in slack so
you know i spent you know weeks months
sort of collecting this spec and then
went back to ryan and said hey like
here's here's what we need to do is the
next phase of this
yeah and so this was fun for me because
this was much less of like a daunting
task of like going in and untangling a
bunch of
someone else's work this was working on
an existing pipeline that we had
implemented you know according to best
practices
and so it was much more approachable
much more exciting to get to work on so
a couple things that have changed at
this point of our journey
you can see just initially you know
google analytics is moving to ga4 and so
that was an easy just integration to sub
out for us we didn't have to do any
instrumentation around that we just saw
that alan brothers excited i didn't know
that happened eric did that because
again i'm not really in the the
rudderstack dashboard at all so at this
point um everything i'm doing
is either uh
instrumenting events which largely is
done i'm not really touching that but
these transformations you'll see so
anywhere there's a like green dot with
the rudder stack logo calling out that's
a custom transformation that happens
within writer's deck so as that data is
flowing through writersac in real time
we can run any javascript function we
like on it to
do some of this cleanup where there's
remapping the fields that you see here
or white listing traits or even reaching
out to clearview in line getting some of
this company data adding that to the
event in flight and so when it lands in
salesforce it already has as you can see
the industry category company size
employees
all that stuff so
um again i'm doing and these
transformations i'm managing off from my
code editor and pushing via api so
literally never going into the router's
user interface i have no idea what
eric's doing in there
we also were able to add slack as an
integration and just filter essentially
those leads that are coming in and just
let everybody kind of see who's signing
up for the app and then um
we have amplitude in there now as well
so there's some dotted lines what we're
kind of noting there is that one of the
things that we mentioned earlier we're
not really showing this just kind of
eliminates some complexity but we're
dumping all of the data that we get
into s3 so we have just this dump of raw
data and so when we decided we want to
use amplitude it's as simple as adding
in the ui we're now fighting data
amplitude but it's not that valuable if
we don't have previous data so we were
able to backfill six months um by typing
that data from s3 to runner through
router stack to amplitude and
essentially we have now an include
instance that's at parity with what
we're looking at in mixed panel or other
downstream destinations
um
and so then you know just to call out as
well these two transformations there's
just kind of some screenshots on here
this first one again is is me living
outside the rotor stack infrastructure
just pushing this transformation that
has a mapping to these fields to kind of
what i mentioned that sales is changing
lead sources or um we want to track
forms via a single event right so i've
already instrumented a form fill event
form submit uh on the front end instead
of having to go in and modify that every
time we want to add a new form or add a
new submission
we just have the form id and the payload
and so this allows us to do is eric can
go in
this is a mapping that i've pushed the
api but eric can go into the ui and
easily when he adds a new form add just
the id of the form and then what he
wants my transformation to map the title
of that to so that um let's for example
in salesforce we don't want someone's
lead source to show up as wf dash form
dash cta page dash you know yada yada it
just comes in as a request demo
um so again this is all managed in
flight we're not having to go back and
distribute events we're not going to go
through dev cycles to ship stuff to our
um to our app or our website and then
this is the the clear that i mentioned
down below and so those are those are
again denoted on the pipeline and then
we're also another thing you'll see
we've added is we're piping that
salesforce and customer io data in via
etl so that we can get that um kind of
user journey data into the warehouse
and we're kind of this was kind of
jumping ahead we kind of found ourselves
going back to snowflake as our source of
truth a lot we're like hey why is this
lead marked as you know a different lead
source in salesforce or why is this
you know user activity being reported
differently in amplitude versus mixed
panel and so this so the don't the
snowflake is always just a place we can
go and see okay these events were fired
in the wrong order or this event wasn't
properly tagged we can go back and fix
that via transformation um so that's
going to kind of lead into
kind of the next step of our journey but
um this was all pretty cool like this is
all again i'm managing it the way i want
to in my code editor um
eric's doing he's doing the dashboard
really not getting each other's way and
again we still have other jobs outside
of this this is just kind of an internal
initiative that we have so um yeah so we
felt pretty smart at this point
we did feel pretty smart
um
cool
so
at this point
we had some of the foundation that we
needed to do what we called like getting
fancy especially because we had like all
this behavioral data in the warehouse
okay
um and the email data as well as a huge
part of that so
one of the big things here was uh we
actually started to calculate like a
very basic lead score right just one out
of five
that was a indicator of someone's sort
of likelihood
um to do like a high intent conversion
okay right and i mean at this point we
have you know sort of five or six
conversion points like it's sort of like
um
really really basic right um
but you know we had some really smart
engineers who like built a really basic
model uh and calculated this lead score
we started testing it we realized like
wow this is actually pretty accurate and
really helpful right the challenge was
it that lead score lived in the
warehouse right because they're
calculating it you know on whatever
their sort of basic like ml
infrastructure is and then pushing that
back
into snowflake our warehouse
the other challenge we had which was
really interesting
was a domain rank
which is like the a number of emails
associated with a particular account for
someone like signing up for rudder stack
and then they invite like four teammates
right
well
those are all distinct leads technically
because they're separate people but
they're part of one single account right
and that made things challenging right
so like marketing automation was
challenging because okay well you have
like someone sign up for the app but
then they invite three people like do
they all need to get the exact same
email like are they doing different
things in the app right that becomes
challenging
and then also it impacted things like
mql counts right it was like okay well
six people sign up for the same app and
that company is qualified
um they need the criteria right so
marketing's like great like our mql
number looks awesome but in reality like
in terms of like a customer
that's eventually going to convert it's
actually just one right
um so
we
we started to look at domain rank right
which order did this person come in were
they the very first person you know were
they like a subsequent you know invite
to the account or
also whatever
was great to have all the data in the
warehouse but we had reporting queries
spread everywhere right so we had some
stuff on snowflake we had some stuff and
look them out blah blah which was a huge
pain
um and then we started to experience
problems with api limits right so volume
is growing we're sending a bunch of data
multiple people are signing up and so
there were some instances where
actually we because runner stack was
recording these behavioral events
we would see these leads come through
and then it would ping the slack channel
and be like oh that's a great logo and
then the sales person be like this
person isn't in salesforce like what
happened right and they were like
well what did happen so
we realized we had the data in snowflake
and we could see all of that on the
marketing side
but but what was happening actually was
we had
we had hit salesforce's api limit we
were literally sending data to
salesforce too fast right and so if two
leads basically hit salesforce
simultaneously it couldn't process them
both quickly enough and it would drop
one
um now thankfully we were running rudder
sockets we had the original payloads and
we could do all that in the warehouse
right but the sales team you know
obviously like that was a really fun
period of like constant slack messages
like
i see the lead in slack but it's not in
salesforce what's going on
so i went back to ryan and was like okay
like
you know we're not dealing with like the
pain of all this direct like integration
and instrumentation
but like marketing is complaining about
analytics stuff and domain rank you know
sales team is complaining all over slack
because the leads aren't getting in
there all that sort of stuff so
this is what ryan did next
so this is the next iteration of our
stacks we refer this as our
typically in this journey we would say
machine learning stack this was more of
like a baby machine learning stack
because we're kind of just introducing
ourselves to this and so
at this point we've built a pretty
robust pipeline um that's really
kind of set up to run a lot of as we
mentioned in the initial slide like a
lot of our business functions like
revenue ops sales marketing everyone's
kind of got the data that they want
living somewhere and so this was really
the step where we kind of combined that
all to where we think it should live so
the the really only changes you'll see
here are
um we kind of took this as a moment too
okay we're doing all of this look ml and
sql and you know some dvt on the day
that we have in snowflake that's what we
trust we're doing some modeling we have
our master user record there and so we
really decided to centralize that around
dbt
and some of the machine learning stuff
we're doing as you can see with
sagemaker and some jupiter notebooks and
so that's all managed where the
analytics team wants to be so they're
not having to do any engineering work
they just get to live in dbt
in stage maker and operate on that data
and provide the models that we need and
then we actually one of the pipelines
that we have at rudderstack is the
reverse etl functionality so all that
that modeling that data that we want to
that we've been the american kind of
image we've been modeling building and
then just manually kind of going in and
uh sales people drooling over and then
trying to get into salesforce we can now
pipe that automatically in on a nightly
job so
um middle of night every night we run a
bunch of gdp models we do some lead
scoring we do some domain rank
a number of things um and basically
those are automatically been typed back
through rudder stack and then populated
salesforce um we you know do that
enrichments and snowflake as well and
then customer io so this really gives us
kind of an end-to-end look at these
customers one of the other things i'll
point out we did is the salesforce
transformation moved um
places from before salesforce to after
kind of around some api limitations and
race conditions
um as we were growing we really wanted
to focus on making sure that we were
capturing all these leads
because of the issue where they're maybe
in slack but not salesforce and so we
really wanted the salesforce lead
creation process to be as simple and
clean as possible so as soon as that
person signs up we create them in
salesforce with nothing more than their
name and email just to avoid any issues
with custom fields or any collisions or
anything
salesforce fires off a web hook that
says a new lead was created and so we
actually send that web hook back through
rudder stack and that's what we use for
enrichment now so we're generating a
lead immediately we're sending a web
hook and so within a couple seconds that
web book goes back through router stack
hits the clear bit transformation gets
us all that
company data that we're that we're
looking for and populates that back in
salesforce so there's a bit of a lag
there but it's not really noticeable
unless you're to be looking at lead
while it happens but it's much more
robust for us
and then again we're able to populate
that into the downstream tools um and
again this is something that that i've
been able to do
with a git without having to touch any
of these integrations without having to
go to the rotor stack dashboard at all
this is all stuff that i'm really living
in my code editor managing these
transformations
telling eric derek which mappings he
needs to manage and then spending some
time with our analytics team in dbt
and sagemaker and really
rudder stack's just kind of taking care
of the pipeline stuff by itself and so
i'm able to
work with engineering on the engineering
side and then work with analytics on
making sure they have the data they need
to build up do that modeling and get
that stuff back into the downstream
tools where the team needs and so
this is pretty great this is um this is
kind of like our full pipeline that we
that we run a lot of our business
functions off of today um
and feeds a lot of other data products
there are there are other a lot of other
pipelines that we're not showing here
this is kind of what i'm going to walk
through because it was the one where we
kind of have done the most iterations on
so um
so that's kind of the ml stack
so at this point i'm happy right because
the marketing team now has like domain
rank and lead score every morning so
that you know let's say someone hits
like a like a lead score of five right
which means it's like a really really
hot lead well we can filter all of those
people out of like the marketing drip
email that's trying to get them to like
you know become more qualified or take
some sort of action
um it also helps the sales team like
prioritize leads all that sort of stuff
which is great all that stuff's coming
in every morning and so like everyone
gets to work and you know everything's
just running all the day where we need
to have it uh which is great so i was
telling ryan i was like hey i think
we're done like
i mean i know something's going to
change at some point like you know
because it's happened three or four
times you know over the last two years
but i was like i feel like we can just
run this like you know for a while and
like we're probably just pretty good
right because
if another team wants to come use a tool
right so it's like customer success says
like hey we want to use zendesk right
well we can literally just go into
rutterstack and add zendesk as a
destination and it will get all the flow
of events like create the users do all
that sort of stuff the reverse ctl will
push like the domain rank the lead score
like all that sort of stuff into zendesk
right so it's super flexible and super
easy
so i was talking to ryan about this and
ryan was like
yeah i don't disagree with you but
what if you could do some of those
things you're doing literally in real
time right like what if you didn't have
to wait for a nightly job
um to get domain right you could
literally instantly have that in all the
downstream tools and i was like well
that's pretty heavy-handed for where
we're at you know it's like a you know
series b um
you know b2b sas company but i was like
but i'll take it like if we can do that
um
and so
ryan started and ryan brought this up
because he had seen several of our
customers build this architecture that
essentially sort of enables like
real-time access to sort of ml use case
data which is really cool so for us it
was like well i mean
again like we don't necessarily need
this but like if we didn't get domain
rank on the fly like right when a lead
is created like that would be pretty
cool because then you know we don't have
to build delays into marketing
automation we literally just know if
this person's like the very first person
who signed up or if they were like
invited to an account or whatever
um
so real time updates on those things and
lead score uh would be cool and then
also like obviously ryan and i are kind
of dirty and so i was like i mean we can
do this so we haven't quite gotten there
but this is what we're going to work on
building next
yeah so the
the cool so one big caveat kind of
this is this is much more of a common
application for like a b2c type
application where we see this a lot with
our ecommerce customers for example
where they're going to use they use this
stack that i'm going to describe a
little bit here um for like what eric
said are there like real-time
recommendation engines or
personalization um or even you know
search results where they're they're
wanting to do some ml modeling in real
time on search results and cross-selling
capabilities so just just take that
caveat again this is heavy-handed but um
the cool thing is
because i'm not maintaining any of these
pipelines because runner said handling
all of the infrastructure
we actually you know even even with this
not being my primary role i have the
margin to finally get ahead of this
right so like everything else has been
like catching up with
teams you know complaining about things
and having to fix pipelines and now
we're at a point where like this is
really running pretty well and i'm not
maintaining anything and so with some of
that margin i have i can actually you
know prepare for something that might
make more sense down the road and kind
of get us ahead for once it's really
cool that you know without even actually
having a day engineering team we
actually kind of have the margin how to
get ahead of this stuff and so um the
only thing that's really changed in this
diagram is that we're piping all of this
data uh again to all these various
destinations in real time but we've now
added redis as a destination and so um
you're not familiar with just you know
just low latency
key value store um and so that gives us
access to push this data into it
immediately we're basically creating a
user profile for every user that comes
to our application so on the fly we're
just creating that that record
and then we're using some of this
modeling that we're doing in snowflake
to batch more um behavioral data or
domain rank or ml models back to rotor
stack to enrich that redis profile so
one example would be um using air
condensed example let's say i'm a data
engineer i've been
uh
you know we i exist as a user profile
i've signed a threader stack i've
actually created some sources and
destinations i've been active in the ui
we're able to see that i've also you
know watched a couple webinars read some
technical documentation and so
i um have a high intent
uh but i'm a data engineer so i'm
probably not the purchaser of rudder
staff and so um but we've got this model
that we've been able to build around my
activity in this redis cache and so then
let's say eric comes and signs up for
the app right and so eric signs up as
head of growth marketing so that eric's
the person is actually going to make the
decision and write the check and
purchase rudder stack and so
in a typical flow eric would come in
we'd have to wait for all this
enrichment and realize that oh hey eric
you know is a new lead but actually ryan
his data engineer has been very active
and so there's a lot of intent here
ryan's probably told like hey we need to
go buy this thing and so air is checking
out for the first time and so what this
allows us to do is as immediately as
eric signs up for the app that redis
cache is going to have the domain rank
associated with me where we're going to
be able to
in a transformation in real time connect
and say hey this is
someone that fits the profile of a buyer
and they have you know associated data
engineer with their domain who's done a
lot of work in the product already this
is a this is a super high intent lead
and also someone would find you to reach
out to and kind of prioritize that so
we're feeding all that to redis and then
we're basically setting up a lambda api
gateway in front of it so that we can
access that directly from those
transformations where i mentioned
earlier where we're doing the clear
enrichment we can now do that um in real
time and have you know super fast access
to all that so the way this would kind
of manifest into b2c is that same piece
as i mentioned would be these redis
caches and then we would be
you know doing some modeling sitting
that in and then this could be done and
a lot of customers are doing it
basically whether it's an api gateway or
something like a graphql server in front
of it where they're actually accessing
that redis cube from the um from the
client side from the front end you know
so they're doing this you know in real
time as a customer is going through
checkout steps or
browsing different products on the
website they're able to
pump some that modeling into redis and
then provide that as real-time
personalization so um again a little
heavy-handed but um you know pretty
exciting to get to work on and get to
get ahead of and again you know at this
point there's still just two of us
managing this entire pipeline it's
neither of our you know kpi and so um
kind of you know allows us to
uh not have data engineering to do this
and have people that are pretty close to
the process and the product um working
on it so
um
yes that's kind of the overall pipeline
so again and i'll let eric speak a
little more to the marketing stuff but
um from the data engineering side the
really cool thing that it allows us to
do and you know i say it's just me and
eric we do have someone on our analytics
team that we brought in and does a lot
of modeling um but even still you know
this is not his primary kpi either but
what it allows us to do
is again i'm not man i'm not maintaining
any pipelines i'm not you know doing any
infrastructure maintenance i get to kind
of gravitate towards where my skill set
or my interest is right so like
getting to you know do set up this redis
and
real time uh situation is something that
is intriguing to me and i have the
margin to do it so i'm able to do that
now whereas benji the other one that's
helping us out you know he's
um he fits like a different data data
engineering is kind of a loaded term
determine what a data engineers actually
do so binge would fit a date engineering
uh profile as well but very different
than me when i'm on the you know private
engineering side formally he's much more
you know heads down sql dvt modeling
type stuff and so for him
to not have to like fight his way
through the engineering side he can
really just focus all of his time that
he has to do this on actual modeling and
then i can focus on the engineering side
that i enjoy more um so it really allows
us to better utilize our internal tool
our internal resources you know human
resources uh to do what we're best at
what we enjoyed working on the most and
then from a marketing side
no more angry slack messages um you know
from people who are out of questions
that's right
no more angry's like messages about data
pipelines or you know lack of data but
no it's great i mean really
um
i think the way that a lot of
or the pain that i think a lot of
companies feel feel
in trying to respond to the needs of the
business as it relates to data
is they start on a path of like very
heavy customization right that's why
every salesforce instance is like a
major frankenstein because you're trying
to bend it over backwards to get it to
do
all of these crazy things that it was
never intended to do
to deal with things that are like
actually pretty simple like domain rent
right or mql definition
and so it's really really nice to be
able to solve solve all of that at the
data layer
in the warehouse and then syndicate
those solutions back out to the stack um
and it's just real and it's so flexible
too right like we're talking about a dbt
model that produces a table
and so if we need to change something
it's very very easy to change that like
very very easy right
uh and the like the ops teams you know
that work in these tools and everything
they love it as well right um
and again like benji
the person who works on the analytics
stuff
if we need to change like a field or you
know all the stuff that happens in a
growing business like you just do that
in the dbt model um and make sure that
the downstream tools can receive it and
then literally the next morning the
entire you know stack gets updated with
this system-wide change
that's happening in a single table
in the warehouse so i also am very
excited to like literally get a lead
score live in the payload immediately
after someone signs up especially like
for domain rank 2. you know like ryan is
saying it's it'd be amazing to know okay
this person gets invited to the app they
sign up we hit the redis cache and we
know oh wow the first person who signed
up is a data engineer who has a lead
score of five right
wow okay this account is hot you know
this is that needs to change like the
emails that we send from the marketing
prioritizing on the sales team and
everything so it'll be really fun to get
that it's fine now but um you know it
would be cool to see sort of that in
real time so
that is uh that's where we're headed and
that's kind of the journey we went on so
we'd love to answer any questions
or hear any thoughts
not everyone at once
why do you choose snowflake instead of
any of the other outdated awareness
do you know the answer i know the answer
you do yeah
they were the first one that responded
to our partnership email apparently
well actually the dirty secret is that
um
there's two things that that is
interesting yeah because we integrate
with all the major warehouses but like
the dirty secret is we actually do
send data to other warehouses as well so
we do actually send data to redshift and
bigquery as well
and benji we mentioned that analysts on
our team he actually prefers google
data studio and so he has a couple of
models and again this is like something
that he's able to do without us even
really i didn't know about it recently
because he's able to do all this on his
own as far as pipelines but he's sending
some of the data to a google sheets
from the warehouse from yes he does so
he can so that he can visualize it in
google data studio because that's what
he wants to do yeah um so we're we're uh
i guess mocking out a big query yeah
that is funny benji has said that i
agree like just using snowflake is nicer
like it's just a nicer tool but it's
kind of like an apple product i guess i
don't know it's just like nicer views
it's like very ergonomic but
that is really crazy so we realized so
benji was building some reports and he
sent them to us in google data studio
and we're like how are you like doing
this you know like we have other bi
tools but he was in like a prototyping
phase so he literally took tables um
from snowflake and pushed them via
reverse etl into google sheets like with
sample data or like a subset of the data
laid google data studio on top of that
did all of the modeling because he's
just really well versed in like google
data studio and like report building
there
and then we like tinkered with report
for weeks and like got it right and
literally it was just an underlying
table on snowflake and so then when the
report was ready for like you know to
share with the entire team and like the
execs and whatever uh we literally just
like laid pablo on top of the table that
he was working on
um
you know in in snowflake and like the
visualization was there was no
visualization work beyond like it was
just like replicate what was in data
studio um which was amazing so like the
ops team was like this is so nice like
it was just like delivering like a an
analytics or like exec ready
like data set with the visualizations
already prototyped in the tool and like
we didn't even know he was doing that he
just literally like pushed it into
google sheets and then did his own thing
which was really cool
what are the sync times uh for data into
snowflake or panos
ah okay this is uh
so you will notice like for for us as a
company like we do some pretty
heavy-handed things in part just because
we can um
so
and rudder sac is it's crazy how fast it
is because i use like other tools in the
past um
so the default same time is 30 minutes
but you can run it actually like as fast
as you want um
so for some things we actually sync it
like every 15 minutes
which again like is is a little bit
heavy-handed
you know for a company of our stage
but like you said we kind of like to do
some things just because we're able to
do it but we do have some um
that's actually not uncommon especially
like for b2c right
like we have really big like you know
you know priceline or kicking barrel or
whatever
um
and for them like real-time analytics is
like every 15 minutes or so right
because they're like running all these
av tests on their website that rely on
behavioral data
and so
they you know it's like running i mean
the big ones are running i don't know
like
hundreds of av tests at the same time
and so they literally dump data into
their warehouse like every 15 minutes
and so like as soon as a test hits
statistical significance
um you know they'll choose the winner
right and so it's like it's basically
real-time which is pretty insane i mean
you know probably not every company
needs to like do like feed the data in
the warehouse every 15 minutes but it's
pretty good so at some other jobs we do
run like
on a nightly basis
yeah what do you hate about it what do
you wish you could do better or what
things are kind of
oh man that's a great question
uh i'll let ryan said well you're so
you're like
yeah i'm on the tech side a lot more
yeah so
that's a great question a couple things
um i'd get rid of salesforce i'm just
kidding um
so one thing one thing that i mentioned
uh and this is actually that is kind of
a possibility that we're working right
now but one thing i mentioned is that i
don't have to go to the ui at all you
know the data engineer i'm doing
everything at instrumentation level and
then i'm pushing code via api to manage
the data in flight
um the one kind of missing piece of that
is that
that eric is doing in the ui setting up
these these various sources of
destinations where benji's doing the
same thing
and so i don't really have any
visibility in that unless i go sign into
the app itself and so um
being able to manage that as code like
terraform style would be really nice
since that's what we're building right
now is the ability to basically
deploy build connect all of these
various sources of destinations in a
terraform
provider and so that way i really don't
have to ever go into the ui so i can i
can pull down the terraform see what
it's set up i can make changes to it
push it back up
and manage all of that be a fair form so
that's the that's the one thing
um we pitch it as being you know this
easier whenever we want to call
ourselves for engineers but that's kind
of the missing piece right now is that i
do have to occasionally go sign and do
things and just i'd love to not be able
to do that
um
what else do i hate that's a great
question um one thing that is that so
there's also like you can probably tell
like ryan and i actually because we do a
lot of this we have like a
really robust relationship with our
product team and so
it is kind of nice because the things we
don't like you know or like features are
like this would be really nice we
syndicate back to them one thing that
we've been talking with them a lot about
is advertising conversions so we didn't
show it in this flow because you know
we're not really a tool built for
marketers but one really nice thing like
as a marketer
is that all the like events that are
streaming you know to the stack here
you can basically take existing events
that have been instrumented so for
example like a form submit
um
call that has a property of you know
request demo or whatever
that ryan instrumented that's getting
like sent to this entire stack you can
actually flag that as a conversion for
an ad platform so an existing event
right so you don't have to deal with
like the nightmare of like okay i'm
doing like the google ads little thing
and then i'm doing the facebook one and
then the red one and all that sort of
stuff
which is really really convenient right
because you're like you can just save
that whole mess um
the thing that we've run into that's
challenging and this is something that's
interesting like we talk about like the
growth stack and the things that you run
into
is like you know initially we were you
know running some google ads and like
doing a little bit of remarketing right
and now we have like you know someone
who's really focused on running paid
programs and scaling that and looking at
cost per lead and like quantity that
converges back
and the api is your marketing platforms
are so inconsistent in the way they do
everything and so
there is actually like some pain on the
instrumentation side and we've had to do
a couple things that are like really
annoying
on the instrumentation side to sort of
get to like meet the requirements of
every ad platform even though
i can technically send a conversion so
for example like linkedin has like a
very specific like json format with like
this id or whatever
whereas like other platforms are just
really easy right they're like sort of
you know you just need to like set one
one particular thing they'll take the
whole payload
so that's one area we're working with a
product team to basically
um
make it easy remove all of the
additional instrumentation to sort of
manage like the
the inconsistencies across those um
so that's that is kind of painful at
this point um but i think we have a line
of sight on how to fix that
and then also the other thing that is
really nice is as more ad platforms
um sort of roll out server side
conversions we're actually
literally just ripping a lot of the like
that direct you know to sort of like to
add platform conversion like you know
sort of flowing through with like an
event payload
and the pipeline that comes from
snowflake
and goes through we're actually reverse
etling where we can all of our ad
conversion server side
which is really nice as well because you
can include like a lot more data
in the conversion
great question
so it seems like what you've done here
you've kind of decoupled the data layer
from the app layer right which is a
very different way of how traditional
customer data platforms have have built
you know uh the products that they're
they're selling what's the advantage of
like decoupling that data layer being
owned in this case by snowflake and then
the app play and we're kind of
managing the data flow uh between the
two what's the advantage of this versus
say a segment
in terms of like why should
companies care about building an
infrastructure this way that's a great
question and i was a really heavy
segment user
before i started using runner stack and
actually before i used router stack
before i joined the company
this is my perspective so
there's
i would say like one thing that's really
nice like rudder stack doesn't actually
store any data right so there's like
there's no data being stored here
there's no data being stored here like
it's just pipelines right
everything lives in snowflake and of
course you know we have esther and a
couple things that
aren't on this chart for simplicity's
sake
but we literally have complete control
over the data and and how it's modeled
how it's shaped like all that sort of
stuff and runner tech dumps it into the
warehouse with predefined schemas
but
before i talked about like making a
change you know just sort of like fields
or whatever across the stack
happens in an underlying table in
snowflake and then it gets pushed out
and syndicated to the rest of the stack
and so
what's really nice about not
we're not like beholden to because i've
used tons of marketing tools and the
reality is they all have their own
database which means they're making
decisions about data modeling and data
types and other stuff like that right
you have to you can't build software
without like actually making some of
those decisions
but that means that you're kind of
beholden to the way that to the
decisions that they've made
right which when you're a small company
and it's not complex like that's not a
big deal
but when you address some of the things
like domain rank or the concept of an
account
like we
build the concept that fits for our
business in snowflake and then send that
out to the stack as opposed to a
situation where
like you know for example on the segment
percentage or something like it's pretty
hard to deal with accounts right because
it's really based around individual
users right and their model of like
building a user record right um
so it's super flexible from that regard
right so we can go to um
really what we do is we go to the benji
the guy who's like building all the dvt
models
and since all the data is structured
like we can we can just do things really
quickly
sort of to meet the needs of our
business
which is cool ryan
yeah i mean
the the wind there for me is
that i i don't know or care what's going
on
like i've been i've instrumented this
you know from the engineering side and
then those tables you know in snowflake
i managed some earlier but now benji
does that so we have kind of a golden
customer record there that fits our
business needs and so like eric
mentioned customers success is
evaluating zendesk and intercom right
now
i don't even know that they're i didn't
even know they're doing that because
like they're able to basically
set up one of those integrations without
going through integration they can they
can connect it in the dashboard
that data is flowing instantly and then
they can just sync that full user record
over from the warehouse and the intercom
is in desk now look like we've been
using it for a long time because our
customers are in there with the profile
in the way that we would want to see it
you know we have
um you know payments attached to it we
have lifetime value we have you know
their sign update all that stuff just
exists and so they can analyze they can
evaluate both of those tools in line
very easily without me being involved at
all so like i'm kind of joking but also
it's like it really is that i don't have
to like get involved with those
decisions because kind of we have our
model we know what it looks like and
like
everyone can kind of use it as a thing
it's pretty fast i mean i know we talked
about it being fast but it is really
nice
to like just be able to run up super
fast right whereas like tools i've used
before
you know it's like three hours six hours
whatever right and so even though we
don't necessarily have to have that it's
that's really nice
i think the other thing actually is like
i'm just thinking about a lot of you
know sort of having a background in
marketing some of the like marketing
type customer data platform things that
i've used or whatever like you do
segmentation and you try to create value
like all that sort of stuff
and getting that out of those platforms
is like extremely difficult
right whether that's an audience or
whatever and so to be able to do that
all on our own infrastructure is
is just super nice um because it's not
like okay well how do like literally in
a lot of cases like
you will export like a giant
flat file of information
you know to sort of like get
segmentation of whatever out
um
you know and then also those things get
really big right and so then you're like
okay well
great like i have to call ryan to like
process a giant flat file to like get it
somewhere it's it's really messy so
those things are just really nice
cool
cool thank you thanks everyone
[Applause]